[Musique]
tartuffe à la comédie-française cela
peut paraître surprenant mais la pièce
n'avait plus été joué dans la maison de
molière depuis 15 ans cette nouvelle
mise en scène est un peu de lentilles
savary un décor très dépouillée et un
texte pratiquement à nu reportage
dominique poncet et marc felix mémoire
et messieurs dans dix minutes dans dix
minutes le début de la représentation
dans 10 minutes merci
plus que dix minutes donc dix minutes
avant que le rideau se lève sur l'une
des plus illustres pièce de molière
tartuffe ou l'imposteur
la concentration est extrême et malgré
quelques sourires le trac presque
perceptible car pour cette mise en scène
des acteurs vont jouer dans un décor nu
aucun accessoire ne viendra distraire
l'oeil du spectateur
les comédiens vont défendre leur
personnage dans votre appui apparent que
le rythme de l'alexandrin evora vie
selon notre andrieu c'est un homme qui
sait vous avez tout de quoi je suis
capable
pour ce qui est vous mon frère en
extérieur et pour tout ce qu'on voit le
voyez-vous meilleur non c'est une
représentation tartuffe la comédie
française dans cette petite boîte qui
recrée un peu le le très tôt parce que
molière c'est vraiment ça avant toute
chose et le très tôt selon le ciel
défendre un certain contentement
mais on trouve à l'est puis les
accommodements selon divers besoins il
est une science d'étendre les liens de
notre conscience et de rectifier le mal
de l'action avec la pureté de
attention on convint on va s'y dit dû
trouver une
comment dire un écho contemporain mais
plus dans le façon de jouer les enjeux
de votre geste qui force à tout y est
presque chaque réplique de tartuffe et
connu la faim mais ça fout les jetons
c'est vrai mais c'est mais c'est oui
c'est extrêmement jouissif c'est ccd
scènes savoureuses 3,6 tartuffe continue
à nous émouvoir
c'est qu'aujourd'hui encore trop de
voyous sans scrupules continue d'abuser
d'un microcrédit
[Musique]